my name is a new Zhang I'm a principal
researcher at the maxim research so our
project is about how to specialize the
audio in order to improve the user
experience in multiparty audio
conferencing so the limitation with the
current the audio company system is that
all the limit voices are mixed into
single channel so you have to spend the
effort in identify who is talking and
what was discussed about and this is
that different from in a face-to-face
meeting in fists of this meeting all the
voices are coming from different
relations so we can use our natural
ability called the cocktail party effect
to tune to the voice from different
duration and we have two scenarios to
this to solve this problem and here is
my colleague itching I have my name is
Jim i'm going to show you the art
technology using the loudspeakers and
here i'm showing the dye I am cerrito
first I will ask you to record a short
message then I will play back what I
heard you can start or stop recording at
any time by pressing the pound key okay
let's get started please record your
message after the tone why is it that
sometimes when you start with an address
in the tension and dogs each hate the
other our offices just completed a
speedy man can beat this track enemy and
out of tommy's feels for me my voice
will be home just found completed how do
email addresses get in your address book
yes what I heard who here was funny for
me so you hear my voice but not much of
the remote there oh that's a middle
position in an ear and I'm talking
suppose only my voice will be heard from
the other signals thank you for calling
goodbye